this is a production of Cornell
University
this afternoon I want to talk about
international horticulture not
international overall because there's a
lot of international that involves
developed countries but to focus more on
horticulture in developing countries I
want to break down the topic in several
ways first the most obvious thing which
you don't probably need is to define
horticulture but then to provide you
with some some examples from developing
countries going up from simplest to more
complex from subsistence to large-scale
and then to take a parochial view and to
explore how Cornell and more
specifically the Department of
Horticulture is engaged in development
horticulture throughout I hope if you
have comments or questions please raise
your hand and let's let's hear what what
you'd like to comment on okay so first
thing horticulture what's horticulture
the science and art of growing handling
and marketing fruits vegetables flowers
ornamental plants woody plants as well
and that of course entails a bunch of
different activities from propagation be
it clonal or seeds through care and
feeding and producing infield greenhouse
etc situations these plants handling
after harvest is a huge component and
very important especially as we go into
warmer conditions so in developing
countries that becomes a big constraint
developing the testing of new varieties
although here it's somewhat conducted by
the plant breeding department but
our geneva colleagues of course are to
some extent breeders of many commodities
transport and marketing have to do with
handling to some extent but again our
huge constraints especially in
developing country situations but then
the other thing that we need to think
about is why are we doing this well
first of all to feed ourselves with
nutritious and balanced meals secondly
the feeding also produces income and
that's very important so many of us are
advising people who make their income
from from horticulture and then lastly
not to be overlooked is the therapeutic
effects of horticulture we like to look
at flowers we like to decorate our homes
with plants all that is horticulture as
well so these are that that's what
horticulture is all about now what
happens when you go to developing
countries and here I'm going to be
focusing primarily on vegetable crops
because that's an area that I've worked
in primarily and one of which in which I
feel perhaps most familiar going up from
low complexity subsistence horticulture
essentially we would define here in this
country is home gardening growing plants
in some cases opportunistically as is
shown in this illustration here it's a
cabbage patch and here's what we would
call a weed growing in it except that
this weed is something that's edible and
so in many cultures in developing
countries they don't weed on time
because they know they can use this this
plant as a spinach this is telling them
but
pigweed celosia various other greens are
considered weeds here portulaca etc etc
but they are used and therefore
deliberately left in the field for some
time until they are harvested the other
situation in this case a picture from
the Philippines a home garden situation
again where we're seeing a mix of plant
some woody in some perennial and then
some would look like just roadside weeds
that's that's actually a relative of
sweet potato that is harvested where the
shoots are harvested and used as a green
so some of them opportunistic in other
cases deliberately planted but not sold
so not producing any income but helping
on the nutrition of the people who are
who are doing the gardening to continue
on that vein in from other countries an
example the top left from Nazir close to
the sahara desert dry season farming
around a compound where they have squash
growing up over the roof in their
harvesting the squash in some cases as a
summer squash in other cases it's a
loofah gourd which they use as
containers so the fruit is allowed to
get ripe and dried and then it's it's
utilized for carrying things to market
etc or patches of greens again leafy
greens that grow well in a warm
condition harvested as an annual can be
found in that situation in some cases
these gardens are part of a larger
horticultural enterprise in this case
southeast Thailand which I had the
privilege to visit last December
and again patches of greens some vining
cucurbit growing their for home
consumption or in some cases from the
same farm as a matter of fact he's
holding a plant which is used as a for
medicinal purposes it's a perennial that
grows there and he just has a few plants
ticking off in the corner he knows what
this one is in that one is in the next
one and it reduces the amount of time he
has to go to to a pharmacy because these
have medicinal properties that help in
in various ailments that people have in
those situations so not income-producing
but used for for nutrition well-being
etc going up in the scale it come to
smallholder horticulture that just means
that the enterprise doesn't cover much
area and it doesn't produce much income
but it can be in many cases quite
sophisticated this is northern Thailand
around the Chiang Mai area in the
mountains nearby quite a large trade has
in recent years sprung up where they're
growing this picture was taken in early
January they're growing under plastic
cover various vegetables cucurbits
peppers tomatoes etc and mostly
marketing those in the larger cities
around or using them for home
consumption this trade was actually
spawned the sponsors are onward but was
supported and and started to a large
extent by a royal project Thailand has a
king and he became quite alarmed at the
opium poppy production which was quite
prevalent in the know
in areas of Thailand and wanted to
provide an alternate for crop production
by the farmers there and so established
a series of experiment stations in
northern Thailand which then explored
and and publicised the kinds of crops
that would easily grow in that area and
could be marketed and the result of that
it's been very successful but here you
see these kinds of smallholders but
doing quite well thank you another
example in the lowland tropics this is
in in Ghana near the city of kumasi the
second largest city of that country
where a couple of young men are
producing lettuce during what would be
and air dry season selling the lettuce
primarily to foreigners or sending it to
the hotels in that part of the country
almost all his hand produced very small
beds the thing that keeps it small is
that it needs to be watered and it has
to be all hand water so he's they've got
a dug well there that they pull the
water out for for keeping these plants
alive so it stays small because of that
another example like this from Zimbabwe
again dry season production with small
holders in this case the organization is
around the community well which was put
there by a British aid project these are
hand pump and the water then is
distributed either through buckets or
through channels in the field so the
well is over here and these beds are
individual beds organises about 20 or 30
producers and they are cooperatively
farming this and they decide who's going
to grow
what in which bed and how are we when
are you going to plant and when are we
going to market it's very well organized
but it took years and years of work to
get that going because you can imagine
in the community farmers tend to be
individual and say no no I won't do this
so they until they got the right
combination of of leaders and farmers it
took quite some time and it these are
fragile organizations that could fail
even though initially they were they
were successful another scheme like this
in rusape and in zimbabwe in the center
of the country same sort of thing we
were visiting and this lady is the
leader of this group of of growers
smallholders in their farming in this
patch behind so again very much
organized and in this case also quite
successful ok so to do this I've
mentioned the challenge of keeping the
the plots watered but the main thing
about fruits and vegetables is that
they're perishable and they're high in
water which means that they're going to
be delicate to handle their most of them
are quite heavy which means that to
transport they are very difficult to
carry from one place to another which of
course gives you problems with marketing
so then you need to have containers to
put these things in this is a picture
from the Philippines where bamboo is
very common and in that situation they
made these baskets
for for the cabbage and you can imagine
how much one of those baskets would
weigh and so okay so you have this in a
truck this size comes by and you have to
get this on to that it's a problem so
people have to be pretty strong but
containers are expensive and so that's a
real constraint the other thing is if he
has three baskets and the truck can hold
15 or 20 who decides whether your load
goes on top or down below so you can
imagine we're talking not only about
perishability here but we're talking
about political organizations sociology
and all the other aspects of
horticulture which i haven't mentioned
before okay so as when we're working
with small holders those are factors
that are very significant and have to be
kept in mind and and will determine
whether the schemes are successful or
not growers small holders in particular
want to grow things that can make money
for them in tropical locations the
lowlands which are by and large flat
tend to be hot have many pests and
diseases and in in often times growing
things like tomatoes or cabbages is not
very easy in the lowlands because of the
problems of pests and diseases and so
the tendency in many tropical countries
is to go up into the hills and when you
go up into the hills you get into
situations like this where you think
somebody is going to have a ski lift but
they won't of course because during the
dry season the cool season is when they
grow stuff up in here but things are on
very steep slopes which means it's hard
to cultivate you have a lot of soil
erosion problems and it's really hard
climbing up and down and then when it
comes to pest control you have someone
with a backpack sprayer logging that
those chemicals up and down the hills
you know aside from the toxicity and
other problems that might occur but the
drudgery involved in in cultivating in
those areas is really quite considerable
as well so farming is not that easy want
to switch now to large-scale
horticulture and to to change the
emphasis of it I think all of us realize
that we are in one world even though
some politicians would have us deny it
and if we if we start with my currently
favorite subject cut flowers almost all
the cut flowers that that we buy here
come from elsewhere and primarily from
the tropics because places like Columbia
and other Central and South American
countries can deliver those flowers to
us in quite good condition year-round
and so that market edge that producers
in tropical areas have they have used to
great advantage and you can see large
expanses of cut flower in this case
chrysanthemums in that case I'm not sure
what's in there but then from Costa Rica
carnations and so on Bill Miller was one
of the ones gentlemen that supplied me
with a picture you can probably confirm
that Costa Rica that came from okay
anyway it's it's one of one of those
country but the fact they can growth
these flowers year-round and supply us
up here gives them that advantage
and we have a flower industry here but
it has a hard time coming up with roses
year-round chrysanthemums year-round
carnations here around alstroemeria
those are probably the big four which
are hundred percent supplied by in North
America by South America Central America
in Europe Africa is is the primary
supplier in those countries another
example again from ornamental
horticulture you may not realize that
you go down to the big-box store and buy
some bedding plants that to a large
extent that those bedding plants may
have come physically the plants
themselves from countries like Costa
Rica and other places as vegetative
cuttings it's a little bit hard to see
in that in that picture but that is what
these bags contain or as seed of hybrids
which were produced with the cheap labor
of the of those developing countries
again Bill Miller is the author of these
pictures I think he could tell us a bit
more about this kind of trade he was
okay yeah and and and and this is seed
production in that case yeah yeah so so
that's something that takes place in the
developing world supplying us in the
developed world and we very much benefit
from the low prices that they are able
to produce this way another example
again back to Zimbabwe where I spend a
fair amount of time is direct production
of African vegetables for consumption in
Britain in this case air freight these
are high value materials such as edible
parted PS
baby corn snow peas physalis a husk
tomato large company using local labor
producing NN squash blossoms which is
what's shown up here and in this picture
here the advantage they have they can
produce during the after the European
winter and can air freight for
relatively little money this product
into London and they have coordinated
the production in marketing to such an
extent that the price it's on the
package is actually already in pounds
and pence ok now that's quite a
sophisticated system that was going
quite well in the 1990s with the
political problems mr. mugabe the
dictator of Zimbabwe that trade has has
somewhat reduced but it's an example of
the kind of coordination that can happen
in a world commerce system now there are
drawbacks to this aside from the
advantage to the London consumer that
they can go into Sainsbury's and by
squash blossoms for their for their
dinner at a reasonable price but they of
course when this got started the
European said now what about the
pesticides and what's going on there and
is it really fresh and so on and so the
Europeans have set up a quite good
integration here with a scheme which
I'll show you a little later on called
the Europe gap g a peek good
agricultural practices that regulates to
what extent pesticides can be used what
the labor
restrictions are in terms of worker
safety and pay etc etc so those things
are quite strongly regulated in the
system that's been set up in many
countries primarily countries in Africa
where the trade is most developed with
Europe an example from our side of
course is the very prevalent and large
production of winter vegetables that are
marketed here everything from squash the
peppers to tomatoes etc are produced
large scale in Mexico and their
production practices are quite modern
except that the Mexican government has
insisted that they these farms don't
save on labor because they want to
employ as many people as possible so
that was at least these pictures were
taken in the night mid-1980s so that was
certainly the situation under in those
conditions at that time and that's of
course very prevalent to the present day
so large scale production that's
benefiting us the the example of bananas
is always one that is intrigued me I go
down to wegmans once twice a week I look
at the prices of things and bananas are
49 cents a pound and apples locally
produced our buck 69
now we're apples coming from okay right
next door and bananas are coming from
Honduras Dominican Republic Costa Rica
Ecuador all this places now how is it
possible for this heavy fruit to arrive
in American grocery stores just when
they're getting ripe in perfect
condition I mean there's no blemish on
if you travel in tropical countries and
you buy a banana and in the store or on
the on the roadside they don't look that
nice we're totally spoiled in our
bananas here I mean there's no blemishes
on them whatsoever and how can they do
that and still just charge 49 cents
pound something to keep in mind okay so
this is global production and global
global commerce now this has been going
for many many years you remember the
term banana republics Central American
countries that where banana is such a
dominant production system that the
politics were run by the companies and
the company's being American had the
force of the American government behind
and so there's lots of politics and very
interesting history that you might be
interested in reading from 1900s all the
way to the present day the situation is
much better than it was then but
nevertheless this one tropical
horticultural fruit really is an amazing
example of the kind of global commerce
that we have at this point and there are
of course issues of producer safety
working conditions welfare which during
the 30s and earlier were very prevalent
and worry worrisome I think things have
have gotten much better since then there
is also a fledgling fair trade movement
as far as bananas are concerned not
nearly as well-developed is the fair
trade coffee that many of us are buying
nowadays it's big perhaps because the
production and handling system of banana
is so complicated and requires so many
actors well-coordinated that it hasn't
gotten further you can't just start a
little banana patch and say hey I'm
going to produce Fairtrade banana you
have to not only produce it but you have
to get it all the way here and that's
not that easy to do ok so what can we do
to ensure that horticulture has a
contribution to make as consumers one
thing we can do is to insist that if
we're getting these products from
developing countries that we are
insisting on s ethical and ecologically
sound systems of production that we're
not poisoning the people producing and
we are giving them a fair wage I
mentioned the arep gap practice which
has now become global gap g AP good
agricultural practices it's a series of
regulations which ties the producer to
the end consumer has been primarily in
Europe but that's something that
certainly it may have spread to other
places I'm not really an expert in this
area but some of you might be able to
enlighten us or not then of course
product boycotts we're quite familiar
with Nike sneakers and other things okay
so that's a possibility if you say well
this and that producer group is not
getting a fair shake I won't buy this
anymore and I'll tell my grocery store
that I don't want this stuff because
it's it's it's not living up to the
standards that that I have so this is
something that certainly is a
possibility as members of the Cornell
community participating in development
horticulture the first thing I think is
to become familiar with the production
system the different products where they
come from who's producing them etc etc
and so that's a learning process we're
very fortunate here at Cornell we've got
a number of courses so students in the
group can certainly get a wealth of
information about horticulture in
developing countries and all the
practices and so on that I've already
mentioned and then from a research
standpoint and extension standpoint
using the knowledge that we have to
suggest changes improvements etc so
that's a very broad statement but i
think the approaches that we have really
boiled down to those two interventions
then i want to in the latter part of the
seminar just give some examples of how
various folks in the Horticulture
Department here are involved in
international horticulture just to give
you a flavor of what's already going on
and I'm fortunate to to have folks in
the audience here that are directly
involved in these activities and so what
I'd like to do is is to ask marsha IM
sively in this case to tell us a little
more about the court I ard 3200 course
that she's teaching Marsha so just
briefly this is a course that's taught
every other
semester will be taught this coming
spring in fact right now we're gearing
up for accepting student applications we
have an information session a week from
tonight about the course and in general
the pictures show what we do there we
prepare for seven or eight weeks
intensively and then we travel and spend
the spring break in Belize we work with
an organization they're called plenty
plenty believes they organize our
experiences in Mayan villages where we
lead garden based learning activities in
the classroom and we also you know
create new gardens alongside the village
residents or we work with existing
existing gardens and then at the end of
the week before we leave we leave a
teacher training good night yes thank
you very much yep so that's one of the
courses that I wanted wanted you to know
about if you didn't already the there's
quite a bit of interest in the applied
economics and management department here
on campus and one of the courses that
taught by dr. Ralph Christie is called
research and strategy in emerging
markets and the the main feature that
involves professors and students from
other departments in this course is the
student multidisciplinary applied
research team which go around during the
winter break to analyze and hopefully
help to solve some problems of primarily
small scale businesses in developing
countries I've had the great fortune to
be involved in in a activity in Belize
helping a cut flower producer in florist
with her business and this last winter
in southeastern Thailand we were
advising a village that was getting into
an agricultural tourism enterprise and
so those have been very interesting
experiences for me others in department
dr. Jane Mount Pleasant
dr. Robin Belinda and perhaps several
others I can't quite think at the moment
Oh dr. ken Mudge have been involved in
organizing the teams and going to
various countries to analyze
agricultural situations China Oh dr.
mark bridgen has been involved in in a
trip last year and sarah hewlett was one
of the participants so if you're
interested talk to them or or us to hear
more about that but it's typically teams
of four to five students with one or two
professors going to a developing country
working with students and then business
people in those countries to analyze in
this case horticultural focused
activities and the sign up for that for
this year's activities is happening this
week if you're interested in that go to
the website of the cornell International
Institute for food agricultural
agriculture and development see fad and
find out where those sessions are or
come and see me after the seminar then
another one and I'm the proud what would
you call it participant the first time I
was ever given 1968 agriculture and
developing nations a fascinating trip
that we took to Puerto Rico and in 11
days during the winter break when you
think it was buried in snow we luxury
ated and went around to analyze
agriculture in Puerto Rico just
fantastic my first time in the tropics
and it was very interesting and
stimulating
introduction the course is still taught
and now is focused on India and India
with all its many complex agricultural
systems is really very worthwhile to go
so here's your chance folks if you want
to go and dr. Robin bellandur has been
involved in or in the organizing end and
conduct of of those trips in India where
she has spent quite a bit of time okay
then another way in which Cornell's been
involved is perhaps a reverse process of
holding international conferences here
were scientists from other countries
including developing countries come to
partake of or share their knowledge with
scientists here Bruce rice dr. Bruce
rice in Geneva the great breeder had a
grapevine breeding in genetics
conference in Geneva which had over 200
participants from 23 countries similarly
Terrence Robinson again Geneva faculty
member held a conference on physiology
of orchard systems with again many
participants from lots of different
countries other involvement more now on
the research and extension side has also
taken place and I'm sure I'm not giving
a comprehensive list here but I thought
I'd call on Robin to give us a few words
of explanation about the activity that
she's been involved in on weed control
Robin
this is kind of an example of being in
the right place at the right time
recognizing problem I started working
with response calories in
McCall in 1996
specifically on herbicide resistant
weeds that were problematic included and
of course with a couple of years we got
started out man I started realize
all the farmers in India and probably
others company for putting on all of
their pesticides for the backpack
sprayer that you call that had a single
one with one novel design and as a
result they were walking from the field
swinging a lot like this well when you
start doing criticized that way it
doesn't work besides plant these pattern
in the field so what we did that
2002 a whole bunch of or workshops
across Ariana includes Evan in order to
have to happen we start teaching you how
to use multiple knowledgeable and how to
walk straight silly but it was a whole
new concept and pictures shown here are
actually developed
gentlemen the opportunities Fred suit
jacket
not there before
conductors are certain that was on my
left and we put on six very large
workshops in January
yeah and to follow up on that is the
local manufacturer of these booms they
already manufacture the the the backpack
sprayer so this technology has become
indigenous Dan's you can see and as she
has said has become very popular indeed
and sponsored a number of Indian
students undergraduates
okay okay great thank you yeah and then
some other examples of international
research that faculty in our department
have been involved in Terrence Robinson
has worked quite a lot in Central and
South America on orchard systems with
primarily Apple but other fruit
commodities as well mark bridgen the zoo
superintendent director of the Long
Island station has had a long
involvement with scientists and end
professors in Chile and his lead
research and planned exploration trips
there and has done some teaching down
there as well Ian merwin has become
quite interested in ground cover
management issues not only here in
Ithaca but also in Chile where avocado
orchard sigh often are found on very
steep slopes and those of you are been
here a bit longer will remember Maya
touch' who did her PhD thesis on on that
work another example is Phil Griffiths
our bean breeder up in Geneva who worked
with Charles wasaga a PhD student in
Charles conducted much of his research
in Kenya on being rust and been
tolerance to heat to heat stress dr. sue
shangguan in the audience to tell us a
lot about what he's doing but I'm going
to save him the the the chore in this
case but he's been working many years
now very actively on senescence research
of plants and has been advising the both
the government and universities in China
on the kind of work that he's been doing
and on research policies related
they're too I was involved for quite a
few years from about 1992 to 2000 in
Zimbabwe on a small holder horticulture
project we worked with the university of
zimbabwe as well as ministry of
agriculture research and extension
agencies to help facilitate production
and post-harvest handling of vegetables
grown by small holders unfortunately mr.
Mugabe the assumption of total power in
two thousand ended our activities and so
it has not resumed except for occasional
visits in set time dr. David wolf has
been involved in Zambia and South Africa
on some soil health issues and visits
there quite frequently dr. Lori drink
waters done extensive traveling etc etc
so there there's a lot of activity going
on in international work on a small on a
short-term basis by a number of people
so what does the future hold I don't I
am I can be rather pessimistic in some
respects our department has only half as
many assistantships as it had only
recently and the sponsorship for
international students has much
decreased Ford Foundation Rockefeller
Foundation USAID used to routinely
sponsor students from developing
countries there's very little of that
still available but I will mention one
tiny bright spot the Cornell
assistantship for horticulture in Africa
was established a few years ago and
sponsors a PhD student to come to
Cornell and
conduct your coursework but then go back
to their countries to do the research on
their on their thesis and our the
current participant in this program is
saman collec if you'll raise your hand
thank you who's working on potato
breeding and potato culture in Ethiopia
and just got back from a summers
activity over there he's working with
dr. Don Hall Seth and Charles wasaga who
worked with Phil Griffiths was the first
participant in this program US
government support of international
projects has also declined but we do
have the collaborative research support
program that's run by UC Davis and that
does provide funding for short-term
projects and we've got a couple of our
graduate students who are involved in in
a support program for short term trips
Brian Sobel and Brian Flanagan Flanagan
will be going on short-term trips this
this winter there are larger
philanthropic organizations we've
already mentioned the tata group but
also the Gates Foundation is sponsoring
a number of activities in which
potentially we could become involved the
other thing which i think is an overall
trend is that we've got the possibility
of involvement in international work in
developing countries in a different way
than we've had in before and as
countries go from developing from less
developed to middle-income countries the
folks that will be working with will be
colleagues rather than students and what
we've seen already is
a sharp increase in the number of
postdoctoral fellows in our department
from these particular countries so this
is something that I think is going to
continue and and provide us with
opportunities to become involved maybe
even longer term with colleagues from
these countries and that then includes
also foreign scholars that would be
coming here on a shorter term basis okay
so lastly how can we engage horticulture
or in developing country horticulture
well the first thing is as far as our
students and through postdocs is
concerned increase our understanding of
what's going on and what the problems
are we can't help until we really know
what's going on but then work
cooperatively with colleagues from those
countries and thirdly to educate the
public so that they have a better
understanding of what horticulture in
other countries what its role is and how
it helps us and then getting involved to
such an extent that we make sure that
those systems that are in place which
are helping to feed us are
environmentally safe sustainable and an
ethical and that is all I wanted to tell
you about if you have questions if
there's time I don't know madam will you
have time Ivan sometimes get out why do
we
you spend time in other countries home
we're being paid by New York State work
for our growers and sometimes growers
raise the question why you want to join
was helping our competition but your we
have time to think about I I mean yes in
some some respects if we're going to to
China because China is starting a big
export industry and strawberry then we
might be a little cautious about doing
that but in many cases were going to
countries that are producing things that
are not in competition with us or our
marketing marketed at a time when we
can't produce it anyway so and and by
going to these countries in helping in
agricultural Affairs more broadly I
think it produces opportunities for us
that we might be able to export some of
our technology to those countries so I
think overall the result is actually
positive rather than negative so I would
caution our producers to think more
broadly than they might be at this point
yeah okay
operations that will presumably run by
Europeans or Americans expats and I
wonder if I'm asking the same thing
right is this is this a trend that
should be encouraged is there a I don't
know that we have much leverage in that
situation I I I think some of the
examples I showed you I may have been
misleading because there are I think
many of the Mexican winter vegetable
production enterprises are actually
Mexican owned and run and certainly much
under control of the Mexican government
so it's not like a banana outfit that
comes in dictates to the country we're
going to do it this way or else but I
think as development comes and as long
as these are positive production systems
that the local people that are working
in those will be the ones that will take
over from from the foreigners so it
doesn't necessarily have to be run only
by foreigners and certainly India has a
wealth of very talented people they can
they you know run many companies that
are very large mr. Tata is very Indian
and a multi-millionaire I mean it's a
very very talented family other comments
or questions yeah Jen
that is true mmhmm yeah land grabs being
a fairly successful attempts by a
foreign foreign to Africa companies to
buy up land to produce a large scale
mostly food crops that then sold on the
world market and this year such a policy
of courses we can see why they're doing
it the corn price is going through the
roof though soybean prices are are
sky-high and so there's money to be made
so these companies have have jumped in
places like Ethiopia was sued and etc
yeah so that that is a worrying trend I
don't know what can be done to control
that if the local politicians you know
who may get a feedback from it and so on
can't be persuaded to say wait a minute
isn't this a very short-sighted policy
that would be my argument but you know
some sometimes bribes
and
preferred practices so that
yeah but I in those companies i would
think that the commodities don't have
the pressure from Europe or America to
feed back to say hey are you really safe
and what you're producing whereas with
with vegetables fruit or even cut
flowers there is that consumer pressure
from this end yeah Geneva questions
comments okay yeah website on going man
afford to this teaching conventional
method versus organic in these
developing countries and I know I for
our ciabatta words you
I guess it depends you on the level at
which the agriculture is at and whether
the focus is on export horticulture or
local horticulture if its export
horticulture certainly producing in an
organic product will carry a premium the
challenges of as you are so aware the
challenges of trying to produce
something in an organic system in the
tropics where you have no winter to get
rid of the pests is really tremendous
and so it's it's a real hard task to
come up with ways of combating some of
these pests and diseases that are around
year-round so so export horticulture is
a very sensitive difficult area to be
working in and if I think if octave oka
has has a choice of of producing or
advising producers of organic export
crops against producing organic or I
would save conventional vegetables
fruits for the domestic market I would
jump at the possibilities of doing that
domestic market instead nowadays
especially in some countries of Africa
notably Kenya the rise of supermarkets
has been something that's come along
very recently so production for those
local supermarkets were city dwellers
have come to expect quality that's much
better than the local farm markets that
they're used to is quite challenging but
doable and the income can be quite
from from such enterprises so if there
was a choice that would be the area that
I would advise and I think I don't know
whether I answered your question who
please please comment plz comment okay I
guess we're done thanks for coming
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu